Hình quyền của bang ngày 15 tháng mô thể hiện lập trường bước vang sau khi tổng thống Mỹ
đồn trường trên bố sẽ chấm dứt hòn và giòn dộ mò và tài chính từ vinh như
trời là trời sang của bà trên mặt sau ở chủ tịch migraine DS cả nèo
khẳng định của bà là cuong ra độ bà từ gió và có chục quyền.
Nhân mạnh không ai có quyền ra lãnh cho la ha bà nè phái làm gì.
Ông cáu vộp mi đã gần sinh anh với của bà xuất hình sau thích kỳ qua và
tình bố đất nước sản sàng bảo vệ tổ quốc lỳn gió tổng mò của quốc.
Hoa chường bố nộ road against thì khẳng định của bà có quyền nhập khẩu
như liệu từ bất kỳ đối tám nào sản sàng cung cấp.
Đúng thời bóc bỏ thông tin là ha bà nè nhật tiền hai lỡ yên
và chất để đồ lại các phố chức an ninh cho nước khác.
Từ bố của cú bà đưa ra trong bố cạnh trong phòng y tổn trọng.
Né gió á, biệt kêu dầu và tài chính từ vinh như trời la, lạc, bà sấu và là ha bà nè đặt
một thật thận về Washington.
Vinh nên giữa la tình là nhà cung cấp dầu lớn nhất cho khu bà
với khoảng 20,5% mỗi ngày trong nằm ngoại
tương đường một nở mất kêu hút nặng lượng của đảo quốc.
Tuy nhiên, giữa lệ vận tà cho thấy các chuyên hàng đã ngược lại
kể thực hiện mi bắt giữ tổng thống Vinh nên giữa la
không đi của la sma road và sét phong tròa dầu mò.
Trong bộ cạnh khu bà khu hằng biệt, thiếu lưng thực và nhìn liệu.
Mình khi cố đăng lỗi lên, nhưng bộ mộn cung thay khẻ dù khối lượng còn hạn chế.
Dạy phần tinh nhận định, tình hình chí chí bắt ổn tại phần như giữa la
cung cấp kêu tình hình kinh tè só hút tru bà thêm càng thang.